Hello, hello, there was no reason for me to loop.
I was actually ready on the first loop, but I just...
I was just ready on the first one, but I was just like, you
know what?
Let me make them wait six more minutes.
Let me scroll on Twitter for four more additional minutes.
Anyway, that's right.
I made you wait.
Looping just for the hell of it.
Anyway, guys.
All right.
First off, dad update.
Oh, man.
Dad, dad.
All right.
So, by the way, remember when he had diarrhea on the first
day back?
By the way, that one time when I was like, please poop, that
was the only...
time he had diarrhea after that he was fine he was like
poops were solid that just that one time i really really
needed him to poop he gave me diarrhea just just as a little
you to me anyway so um today um today i took him to the dog
part for his you know his morning pee and poop you know his
morning routine and uh so um usually he's very antisocial uh
he ignores all the dogs but and uh but he only like he's
only happy when there's a very when there's pretty ladies
pretty owners let's just say at the park so there are two
guys there already at a dog park and one guy had like three
dogs there were like four dogs and he ignored All the...
Okay, actually, no.
There was one guy at first.
Sorry, let me start from the beginning.
There was one guy at first, and he had three dogs.
Dad ignored all of them.
One of them tried to, you know, be like, Hey, you want to
play?
Hey, there, new guy.
Do you want to play with us?
And he was just like, fuck off.
Like...
He was just like, fuck off.
I don't acknowledge him.
He doesn't even, like, acknowledge him.
He just walks away.
They'll, like, be smelling them and everything.
and he just ignores them as if they don't exist and then uh
you know and then the owner would be like oh hey you want a
pet and dad would just be like fuck off fuck off don't touch
me man he's like don't touch me over your manly hands fuck
off he's like gross not a pretty lady you're not allowed
And then, so he's just walking around the dog bar.
He doesn't care about anybody there.
He's just like walking around.
And then another owner came in.
And I don't know what it was about this particular dog.
But I think maybe it was a girl.
It was a female dog.
But he got so excited.
He's like, oh my God, you.
I think it was a female dog, honestly.
And he's like, you, I'll give you the privilege of having me
acknowledge you.
you.
His simple mind.
I think he was super chat.
Thank you.
You know why he acts like this, right?
Doki is just to spite you for making him leave his home.
He was super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He's like, hey, you.
And then so he like walked up to this other dog.
Didn't care about the owner, of course, because he was a
man.
And then there he was like, at first the other dog did not
really want to, like the other dog didn't want to do
anything with him.
And then he's the other dog tried to run away.
He was like, come on, come on, you know, you want to play
with me.
And then, you know, the other dog was like, you know what,
I'll play with you.
Then they just started like, um, I guess like jumping at
each other.
Like, ah, what's the word called?
Like, like, like pouncing on each other and stuff.
And with like arm wrestling and stuff on each other, like,
like where they put their arms on the shoulders and to start
wrestling with each other and everything and flipping each
other over.
And then the other three dogs one of the dogs that from the
other owner came over and was like oh you guys are playing
can i play and then the other dog would start barking at my
dog and the dog that he was playing with he's like hey can i
play he's like i want to join rough rough and then dad was
like no i'm even so mean and dad was just like can i play
rough rough hey guys like just standing there was like
wrestling and stuff and then dad stopped wrestling looked at
him and it's like no get away from us he's like and he
started chasing him away you know like the he's like like
you know started showing his like mouth like his his he
started snarling at him his fangs he's like hey he's like no
get out and then the dog was like and he's like chased him
off and the other dog kept coming back he's like please can
i play and he's like no And then he like chased him off like
three times.
Yeah, he buried his teeth.
And it's like, no, this is my time.
Yeah, he was mad.
And he started like chasing him off and stuff.
And then like, and it resumed the playtime of the other dog.
And then, so they were playing.
It was having a great time.
And then they were both having a great time playing and
everything.
The third owner came over and it was a pretty lady.
Plot twist.
So you know that meme of like the guy looking at this, the
third girl while the girlfriend was like, what the fuck?
Okay, so that's sort of basically what happened.
So the pretty lady owner came up, like came over to the dog
park and then dad stopped playing.
And he was like, And he instantly walked over to her and was
like, hi there.
He like, and then the other dog was like, why are you stop
playing?
And then the other dog started following.
Dad's like, come on.
Come on, don't you want to play?
And Dad ignored the other dog.
I said, the other dog didn't even exist to him.
He's like, I don't care about you anymore.
And he just kept following the owner everywhere.
uh and then the other dad was like come on don't you want to
play he's like come on like following dad and dad doesn't
even acknowledge the other dog anymore as if like they
weren't even roughhousing or playing or wrestling for like
15 minutes as if they were as if they weren't fucking
wrestling even though he was the one that was chasing after
the other dog to ask ask the other dog to play and
everything it's like all that never mattered to him like
he's like i don't want to play with with you anymore and he
just kept following the owner everywhere he's just like not
even acknowledging the other dog and i was just like i was
like that's up bro like all that effort just to throw them
away just like that he's like she's a real woman she'll
you'll never be like like she has hands to touch me
and then so then he started following the other owner around
be like hey you want to touch me you want to pet me you
remember me right like and then and then the other dog was
like I want to play and then he just the other dog just
sadly walked away because like dad was not giving the other
dog any more attention uh why are you thinking because he is
he's a freaking creep who just fucking stop playing like
stop playing with his friends just to chase after a pretty
lady who does that what happened to what happened to bros
before hose what happened
He told that dog she was old.
Me, I do that.
Good chunk of guys.
What happened to bros before hoes, bro?
What happened to them hanging out with your homies?
Flays, good.
That's not a bro, bro.
Yeah, he's filing the bros before hoes rule.
Nuppers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He knows what he wants.
Respect.
um anyway other than that um i love rem i love him so much
he's my little chud the littlest taniest eeppiest fat little
chud i love rem rem rem rem rem anyway i've been uh playing
deadlock the last three days and all i've been doing is just
playing rem um i just i i'm so fucking ass at that character
and also the game by the way because i don't play mobas but
like i tolerate everything i hate absolutely hate and hate
so i hate that's like hate and loath everything i hate and
loath about deadlock i hate deadlock so much but i'll do
anything just so i can be rem my little chud man my little
chuddy little guy my fat little chud
um so uh basically i got two hour ban last night um um i got
you know it was my third day of playing deadlock and i
already got two hour ban because I absolutely hate the game
when I'm not on rem I'm it's so miserable when I'm not
playing rem I so basically this standard by the way if yeah
if I don't get to the play rem I leave if I leave too many
times I get bad so it's not like I left like every game or
some shit but it was my um it was the second time I left the
game and it was standard it's not like I left in the middle
of the fucking game too I just see I'm not not rem no play
you know yeah so I got a two hour lever penalty because it
was my second time doing it on the second day by on the
third day by the way so I was just like second day um I left
one time because I was like not rem no play and then because
I was like it was my first time I did and then on the third
day I was like not rem no play and then it was a two because
the first time apparently is a 15 minute penalty and then
the second time it was two hours and it was standard by the
way and I tweeted it but people took it so seriously I saw
like one guy was like was like what was it people like you
ruined the game and I'm like bro I left before the game
started I bet The match just canceled.
It's not like I left in the middle of the fucking game.
Like, I'm like, bro, this is standard.
Like, it's not even rank.
Like, people are like, you are, like, you better leave.
Like, yeah, don't ever come back to Deadlock.
And I'm just like, damn, what?
It's like, I just left the quick play.
And the quick play hasn't even started.
Like, yeah.
at best you just at worst you just re-queue it's not like
it's just five more minutes of re-queuing uh yeah um but i
love rem i love him so much i just i don't know just
everything about that character just ticks all my boxes
about like like character design like how he looks how he
talks he moons, how he looks, I know I said that again, how
he presents himself.
Like I just, oh my gosh, how can you be mad at that little
face?
Like he's just an eepy little chud and I just love
everything about him.
Like, but then the worst part, okay, like N-A, it's fine.
N-A, I always get REM.
And then I would play on EU servers and I never get REM.
I don't understand Every time I left was in Europe, by the
way.
Which was the two times I left.
And I would tolerate the other times.
But, like, I was like, I've had it.
Because I think I played, like, in European servers, in EU.
I played, like, six games on EU.
And I had one game as Rome.
And I was like, why?
Why can't I play Rome?
why that's all i want and i was like i was like i hate your
service i hate i was like to my friends i was like i hate
your service i hate your service i just want to be rem i
just rem rem rem give me rem i just god i'm sorry i i was so
mad i was so fucking mad because that's the only reason why
i play this game is like rem or throw and it's not even
intentional throw i just anything else I have brendler feed
exactly uh Dr Cremberry thank you the super chat thank you
thank you um Rem and Hayes know each other because they
always see each other in people's streams a bit for a
completely different reason think of a super chat thank you
thank you I I wish I just hate that cat one trick in
deadlock I just don't understand why can't I why do I have
to learn all these others I don't care about these other
characters I don't about them.
They're all miserable.
I hate all of them.
I just want to play rem.
I hate the whole system of movas, but I just love this
little guy so much.
I'm literally doing it for him.
I'm literally tolerating everything I hate about movas, and
I'm left to right.
I don't care.
I don't care about what I'm buying.
Left to right.
Q build.
I don't even buy my own items.
I take a screenshot of the ability point thing.
Every time I get the ability, I look to my right monitor.
I see the ability point.
And I'm like, oh yeah, I should do that.
I don't even know what ability points to upgrade in the
order.
Left to right.
Rem.
I just want to play Rem.
I can't fix it.
I'm tolerating the ability.
entire genre for one character.
I don't know how to mobile.
I don't know how to farm.
I don't know how to rotate.
I don't fucking care.
I don't care.
I hate farming.
I hate rotating.
I hate doing boxes.
I love taxing the sinners.
I hate doing lanes.
I just want to fight.
shit I but I love rem I love him so much I I love rem so
much that I will tolerate all of this just so I can be rem I
just so I can be a little chud Gordon thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you my oh she is throwing because
she does couldn't get her one trick shake my head what is
your Where is your desire to win?
I'm not even throwing tenet chili.
I just don't know how to...
I just don't know how to do anything else.
I just only want REM.
I...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Gordon.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
DPS, add Rem to Bomber Bird now.
I'll patch the game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I love Rem.
Guys, I love Rem to a very normal degree.
My Oshi channeling the true essence and soul of a Mova
player.
District, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just...
I just think he's so cute, guys.
Oh, yeah.
I just think...
I just think he's so cute.
Fun Vault.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the thank you.
But yeah, anyway, so I started playing Deadlock three days
ago.
I do not have a...
My win rate on REM is actually pretty bad, though.
It's actually pretty bad.
I'm so bad at rotating.
I don't fucking know what I'm doing.
I just, I don't know.
I'm like, oh, boxes come up at two minutes.
Cins come, camps show up.
Oh, sorry.
Cams show up at two minutes.
Boxes show up at that.
You have to rotate this.
You have to have a box around.
you have to get your camps you have to get the sinners and
i'm just like i'm a chud i'm a chud i'm a little chud i'm
go to the tunnels and i'm like i'm a chud i'm a chud i'm a
little chud Rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem.
Rem, rem.
Why play it so?
Because I get to be rem!
I get, that's all I want!
I get to be rem!
That, that's what makes it all worth it.
I get to be rem.
I get to look at that little guy.
oh my and his mods are so cute too uh i don't i don't mod
the game or anything because i know i'm gonna get so
disoriented if i mod to give i change my red skin and i'll
be like what is this i don't remember that i i lose all my
muscle my lack of sorry i barely have muscle memory but i
know i'll lose like everything i've learned about the game
the the one percent of everything i've learned about the
game uh i am i am the spy man playing rivals except i'm rem
i just want rem and someone said you can make all if all the
characters in the game rem but then i wouldn't want to shoot
them because he's rem he's just a little oh yeah there's one
we can replace like there's like one where he's just a tall
like big rem but it's like it's like those it's like the
what's it called the back rooms guy where he's like
elongated i was like bro i don't i I don't don't ruin rem
for me, man.
Don't fucking ruin rem for me It's I it's all I have in
deadlock.
Please don't ruin him for me, please Rem is all I have is
I'm only playing deadlock for him.
Please don't do not ruin him for me
It's it's all I have
Duck thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you legally distinct rem skin suit when and then by
the okay it's really bad i once i i had like 5k damage at
one point during my first day of playing i had like 5k
damage i'm like guys i don't know what i'm doing guys but
i'm rem i'm improving though today i had 18k today i had 18k
on the first day it was 5k but today i went up in the world
now it's I'm slowly climbing at 18k.
They're like 5.4.
But guys, but I'm REM.
I'm REM though.
REM, REM, REM, REM.
Like, I'm just a little chud.
What can I say?
Slowly moving up in the world, everyone.
Left to right, I don't think for myself.
to the shop it auto buys everything for me and i'm satisfied
i i i was like i think i have enough go to shop and then i'm
like all right back to doing rem stuff i don't even open the
shop i let the i let the ai do the thinking for me left to
right q build that's it Don't even look at what I did What
what I'm building I don't know what I have Q build
Alright sorry I had to Dedicate the last 10 minutes to REM
Sorry the last 20 minutes to REM Um
Um Um Today finally gonna be checking out bomber braid uh
for those uh do you even know nope i don't know what my
items do q build left i found the builds i only use i refuse
to use any build that is not left to right q automatic buy i
oh you're supposed to buy counter items also i i am so mad
that You can't swap characters in standard, by the way,
because like, um, because like, you know, you have to pick
three characters, so, um, at one point, the lowest priority
character gave, they gave me the lowest priority character,
and then even though, like, um, like, someone already took
Rem, but I had seven as my second priority, because seven
was the last character I actually knew how to play.
Um, uh, new is a very loose term there.
and then they gave me my third character who i was just like
i don't know what to do for my third one and i just i went
and did like um i went and was like okay so i don't really
know what to do for my third character so i was just like uh
this guy looks cool and then they gave me my third character
i i was just like why can't i change i should should be
allowed to swap characters during standard like it doesn't
make any sense why um why they won't they let you do that in
rank but they won't let you do it in standard and so dumb
sorry i lost my train of thought what were we what were we
talking about before i complained more about deadlock
um no rem is my highest part don't worry i rem is my highest
priority all right so Oh, yes, you were talking about Rem
more.
Sorry.
Bomberbird.
We're finally going to check out Bomberbird.
Sorry, I'm so sorry.
I got really distracted about Rem, who is my sleepy little
chud.
Oh, my God.
I love him so much.
He's such a cute little chuddy, sleepy boy.
Little bird boy.
Sorry.
Bomberbird.
So, Bomberbird.
was made by
Bomberbird was made by your fellow dragoons and you know
what's crazy okay by the way sorry good job on the mods good
job on the mods I'm pretty sure they are bots but someone is
actually paying money paying their own money to get Insta
banned in my chat and I do have subscription mode on So
they're paying money to try to bot my stream and then get
banned.
I mean, it's your money.
Do what you want, I guess.
Like, it's your, do what you want.
Thanks for the, thanks for the sub, question mark.
Yeah, they have to sub to me first to be able to chat, by
the way.
Do what you want with that money, I guess.
Anyway, so it was made by your fellow dragoons for my
birthday.
And it was a while.
It's been a while since I was able to check it out.
Since there was so many.
There was so many things going on this month.
fine check it out and i remember seeing it and i was like
you guys put so much hard work into it looks amazing bomber
man is like one of my favorite games growing up um i used to
like play a bunch of bomber games growing up i love the ones
where you can stand a little sit on the little kangaroo in
bomber man i loved i always dragged my dad and my relatives
to play with me when i was growing Sorry, my voice is dying
because I proclaimed my love for Rem
I was I lost my voice because I'm like Rem Rem Rem
I just I just I you don't understand I I just love Rem so
much Rem took my voice
All right anyway anyway but um we're looking for trying it
checking it out because i never haven't been able to i'm
able to have time to check uh the birthday gifts you guys
got me and everything i really appreciate i really
appreciate everyone um working so hard in this game and all
these gifts you guys got me for my birthday i can't wait to
look at it right now uh all right let's check up let's check
out bomber bird it's okay dokey don't cry regent thank you
this super chat thank you thank you so yeah huge shout out
to the dragoons who made this game i'm really excited guys i
really am super excited um let's see bum bum bum bum bum bum
bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
bum bum bum bum okay
there's apparently an intro too oh by it oh there it is yay
all right so i know here are the people that made
Bomberbird.
Bomberbird by Dragon Project Squad.
Game 3.
Wait, I know these people.
Programmer Lean.
Alright, guys.
Okay, I know I'm talking about Bomberbird, but guys, I...
I hate the farming mechanics.
I hate the farming.
I'm always so under farmed in Deadlock.
I just don't know.
I don't know how to farm in Deadlock, guys.
I just...
don't fucking know every time i'm like 10k i'm dad please
please i'm i'm dancing here anyway it's like immersion it
just i just i i don't know i'm only 10k under i compared to
everybody else how do you farm in deadlock how do i do box
rounds how do oh my god
When do I know?
I was looking a sec, let me give him, I just wanna be bram.
I'm gonna be dad real quick.
Also, you were like, why don't you play street brawl?
Cause none of my friends play street brawl.
They just wanna play normal deadlock.
So I have to play normal deadlock.
because I just never grew up with Mova so I'm just my head
cat okay let me there's me ranting about it they're like how
are you enjoying deadlock this is what I said okay let's see
let me read this real quick I kill me kill jungle free I
don't know I'm always lost and disoriented confused.
I always forget where my tunnels are too.
I was like, I'm gonna do tunnels.
And then I'm like, where's my tunnel?
Wait, which way is my tunnel again?
I'm
I'm like, where do I, where do I go?
Where's my tunnel?
I do.
Alright, let me see.
I just don't like farming.
I don't understand it.
I hate the farming and rotating.
I'm always confused.
I just want to be told what to do.
When fight happens, I'm not confused, but fight over.
What do I do?
But it's like, when do I wave?
When foxes?
When I return.
I hate mobas.
That's just me just yelling into the void.
is a REM expert, then you should ask her for tips.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Spoken like a real MOBA player.
I think I have more, let's see.
After two years as the project lead, I'm so honored you're
playing a game.
It's been a long ride, but worth every second.
Also from the game's only pixel artist, thank you so much.
I hope you like my work, of course.
It looks amazing from the, from the main game screen alone
it looks so good but thank you for the super chat congrats
on all your hard work man you did so good I it's a good
takeaway okay let me see I know I said more I still don't
know how to move up farm I feel like my biggest biggest
problem is I don't know how to rotate I'm just rocking it
around in circles.
Ah!
I'm just screaming in the voice.
I'm like, I hate farming.
I hate deadlock.
I hate mobas.
I just want a one trick.
I, that's all right.
There's, don't worry.
You're like, is that it, Toki?
There's more.
Excuse me.
Here you go.
All right, here we go.
Where was it?
I was like, someone was like, I assume you were deadlocking.
And I was like, I was.
What was that rat call?
They said, and I was like, Rem.
And then he was like, Rem.
And then I was like, Rem, Rem, Rem.
I like Rem.
I hate everything about deadlock, but I like Rem.
He's cute.
I really like his character design.
I played deadlock for Rem I left two games back because I
couldn't get Rem and got a two-hour ban This game sucks so
much when I can't play Rem.
It's so miserable Rem Rem
Rem I
Just kept spamming Rem I
I'm like, rum!
Literally, I'm talking like a Pokemon.
Please just let me one trick.
I don't care.
Because I like rum to a healthy amount, guys.
I it's it's a very a very healthy degree of the that I like
REM uh quick remedy keeps the voices at bay okay all right
bomb and burning i'm super excited oh apparently yes sir and
by the way you can you can download the game on steam right
now by the way oh super super secret codes here oh what are
the super secret codes Okay, we'll do full screen.
I assume the controls are like very, very intuitive.
It's up, up arrow key.
Okay, I do.
I'm just gonna, just in case.
Whoops.
Just in case.
I got LDWSD.
Bomb.
Oh, let me do middle mouse button for this.
If you can.
Um.
If you can, let me be able to buy.
uh let me be able to buy mouse buttons if there's an update
for that room detonate pause all right let me know the sound
is good too yeah i'll link the game on steam too so you guys
can check it out i can't i'm super excited you guys are
adding planning on adding multiplayer version in the future
it'll be fun i would love to play this again if i melt
multiplayer is at it uh you can download the game here
all right um replace pin i always use i mean i use my melee
is bound to uh mouse button for i think i feel like that's
just a general thing i feel like usually people play fps
would find their melee button on their mouse keys or their
mouse buttons and that's for me i mean it sounds okay guys i
love rem
i won't be legally distinct rem i just come out with a new
skin suit and i'm legally distinct rem i don't like it guys
it's me the rem bird
unrelated to rem from deadlock all right here we go short
campaign oh boss rush i will do the short campaign the
artwork's a Amazing.
And shout out again to owner.
I love Pixar.
And you did an amazing job with everything here.
Cause I know Pixar is really hard too.
Because you know, every pixel counts when you're doing pixel
art.
You don't want it to be like too blocky because it'll look
like a little too messy and everything.
So this looks amazing.
Thank you so much.
You guys obviously put so much love and attention to it too.
Especially backgrounds too.
Pixel art background is like, oh my gosh, it's like so
aesthetically pleasing.
to look at too so yeah yay please check out the game guys
it's on steam and it's free too i love room oh i'm sorry i'm
i love him he's so cute uh i'm maddie thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you i close my eyes i'm still I'm
still thinking about him.
This is my new Oshi, guys.
He's almost there.
He's second place.
My number one Oshi is me.
But he's getting there.
He's climbing the leaderboards right now.
If Rem and the dragoons are dangling on the cliff and I can
only save one person, no comment.
Fiery.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I guess we'll find out in the next episode who she's gonna
save.
Who...
You would understand, right, dragons?
You would under...
Whatever choice I make, you guys would understand.
Right, guys?
Zechra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll give you an Aka soup, but don't mention REM for at
least an hour.
MIR, I love MIR.
MIR, MIR, MIR, MIR.
MIR, MIR, MIR.
He's so cute.
MIR.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec real quick.
Let me Google something real quick, guys.
I think I have too many tabs open.
My PC might be a little slow with all these tabs.
I love rapid eye movement sleep, guys.
Rapid eye movement sleep.
Rapid eye movement.
Alright guys, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
I'm going to buy a rapid eye movement costume and show up to
your next meeting lead in Toronto dressing it, a foolproof
plan to get do get on me.
I hate the whole concept of MOBAs, but I'll do it all for
rapid eye movement.
All right, let's go.
Let's try it.
All right.
Where's rapid eye?
Which one do we do?
Oh, who do we want to be?
Wait, there's so many characters
Ah, okay, that's fine.
It's the same right It's always like it's mowing krill rapid
eye krill
Close enough All right, how do I plant with a new umbrella
plant?
the bombs WSD Z and C okay I'm laying like I'm laying bombs
right now how many bombs do I get some more rapid eye
moments coming in we just got just gotta lock him in oh oh
he dodges it oh unlucky God, I joke.
Oh my god, he paused?
Wait, are you real?
Oh, you're real.
Easy.
You just get everything?
I want it.
Everyone else is dead.
Look at that.
You just get all the boxes?
What are the music?
music's fire though oh my god the background's so cute look
at stokey lot oh wait there's my portal oh there's my two
portals oh I have to find the portals oh hey there oh hey
for that all right okay I I didn't realize they were mine
not gonna lie to be fair i actually forgot i didn't realize
they were mines guys i didn't realize he was laying eggs
what the fuck holy shit this ai is crazy
is he gonna explode did he explode himself oh oh i mean sure
i'll take that i guess he that's the only way i can win he's
gotta take himself Take himself out.
What happened?
I take those.
The smartest tomato out there.
Oh, it's the beach.
Oh, no, what's the...
Oh, I fucked up.
Oh, it's speed.
Okay, feather is speed.
He locked himself.
Look at this video.
He locked himself out.
Oh, I'll kill him.
Okay.
All right, I need to know his this AI path thing.
That's right.
What you gonna do now?
You're trapped.
It's the beach episode.
I think I should grab upgrades before I go kill them.
Whoops.
That's not what I want to do.
That was a little bit of a waste, but I'll take it.
How many bombs do I have?
I have three, I think.
Let me double check.
Okay, I have three bombs.
Oh, the background is so cute.
I'm trying not to get too distracted by the background.
Just want to look at everything that's going on.
He's just so cute.
Alright, got him.
Alright, I gotta get that one guy trapped in there.
Give him a taste of freedom before we kill him.
This isn't a beach, this is a bathtub.
There's no drowning dragoons though.
Not accurate to the dokey beach.
Where am I drowning dragoons?
Oh, nah.
I feel like I should grab upgrades before I go.
The dragoon's chilling while Dokia is fighting for her life.
Just like how I would do that to you guys too.
I'm going to see if I can grab some extra upgrades before we
go.
Oh.
Are there extra upgrades?
Or is it like...
Because I don't know.
I don't... I'm timed.
I just realized that.
There is nothing.
Oh, wait.
There is punch.
Okay, I can punch them now.
Okay, let me experiment with that.
Oh!
Okay, it's Z.
I need to remember it's Z.
Don't worry.
Rapid eye movement.
I'm here for you.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, multiplayer is gonna be so fun too.
I think that's like the best part about Bomberman.
The chaos of multiplayer.
It's just such a good party game.
I wish...
I wish the Bomberman IP isn't, like, partially dead.
That's, like, the thing that makes me so sad.
I wish the Bomber IP was not partially dead.
Oh my god, Snuffy!
There can only be one.
What the fuck?
How does she have a...
And she can... Okay, why does she get everything?
Okay, maybe she'll bomb herself like a tomato.
Okay, that's fine.
Holy shit, she's so OP.
Oh my god, it's like an entire line.
I don't even want to go near her.
It's actually the cross.
Oh, oh.
Sure.
that she won't lock me up here.
I'm just a little guy.
I'm rapid eye movement.
Okay, at least she only has one bomb.
That's like my only saving grace right now.
Is that she only has one bomb.
Oh, this is going to take forever.
My bombs are so weak.
Oh, I should have got more upgrades.
It's not how big the bomb explosion is.
you use it oh
my god there should be a cool down i don't even want to go
through
but i got her i hit her oh this is cheating but she's
cheating
Oh my god, she's just kicking it!
Oh!
What?
Yeah.
Oh my god, she should have a limit to how many she can kick.
It's legal!
That's it.
My turn.
Oh my god, wait!
I can stun her?
What the fuck?
She's just pooping boxes.
Oh my god, I fucking saved your life.
Oh, come on, Stuffy!
I only have 40 seconds to kill you!
It's not fair.
This is not fair.
She even knows like how the explosion linked.
Okay.
back in here.
Oh my god, you bitch.
You bitch.
You actual...
I don't have enough bombs!
It's okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I
would, I wish I could just chuck you right now.
I wish I could just chuck you right now.
Oh my god.
Ah, you fucking are!
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
It can't be, I can't do F.
Oh my god, can't even do mouse click?
What can I do?
Shift.
That's another bomb.
Oh, shift is not the right one.
Shift is absolutely not the right one.
Shift is not the right one.
It has to be Z.
she's so oh she shouldn't she should not lower the cool down
lower the cool down
i'm gonna die with me if it means i'll live
Bitch!
What the fuck?
How can you be stunned for that short of a time period?
You bitch, you bitch, you bitch!
Okay.
Oh my god, you fucker!
Ah!
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, I just can't kill myself.
Alright.
What does blue mean?
Blue sound looks like a good place to be in.
That damn raccoon.
Whoa!
Oh, I'm at the market!
Oh.
I'm on the streets.
The streets of Dokeloon.
Okay.
What the fuck is that blob?
Oh, is he like really smelly?
Did he not take a shower?
Is that what it is?
His aura?
Is that his aura right now?
What is he doing?
me an upgrade what is that why is it blinking oh he just
gives me free upgrades
all right i mean i'll take it free is free what is what are
the stars
I can keep feeding me these upgrades.
Oh, oh, it's invulnerability.
Oh, okay.
All right.
I'm just going to keep feeding him.
Eat my longoon.
Eat.
Oh, it's like a Mario star.
I see.
Eat longoon.
Yes.
Oh, shit.
No!
Don't die.
Okay.
Yes, keep eating.
Om-yum, don't worry.
I'll feed you.
I'll feed you, my little guy.
Don't go there.
It's dangerous.
Don-yum, keep eating.
My little Long-yum, yes.
Keep eating is so delicious.
Om-yum, yum-yum.
Yes.
Keep eating more.
Oh, no, he's not.
not eating.
Longo, yes!
No!
My golden goose!
I got too greedy!
Oh, shit!
It's Doki!
Okay, what is Doki special?
What is that?
Oh, hey.
Nice.
I mean, okay.
I mean, all right.
She's fast.
Oh my god.
What is the pick?
My what up?
Rewind.
Oh shit.
It's rewind time.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
I can't even go in.
She's locked me out.
Don't worry, she doesn't know how to...
Wait, she's unlocked.
Oh my god, how many HP do you have?
It's rewind time.
Oh, shit.
I got a little too cocky there.
Come on, rewind time.
Rewind time.
It's rewind time.
Oh, no, don't grab it.
Don't grab it.
stupid don't do anything yes she's trapped it's rewind time
oh oh oh she's dumb yes she's so stupid thank god oh this is
where i killed school dokey right why was she easier than
snuffy what what are the power levels what is the balancing
here whoops wait that was a little premature oh
she's lower accurate yeah make sure i don't die from these I
got the extra bomb.
All right, let's see if there's any extra power-ups, though.
Oh, nice.
Power-up.
And grab all the power is possible before I go in.
I think the next level is another boss fight.
Vives, base.
balancing.
What is the power scaling here?
All right.
Let's see.
We got all the power-ups.
Let's go in.
I swear.
Okay.
I was going to say if that was...
We'll never know what's in that box.
I was going to say.
I swear to God if that...
Oh, no.
No.
Not the mines.
Maybe she'll step in our own mines.
Wait.
Can she do that?
Can she step in her own mines?
Oh, she's stuck now.
Oh.
okay
she's stuck oh no oh no I'm stuck oh
so she can't move in her own minds oh no but there's so many
now I don't remember where they are I already forgot where
they are I don't use the gloves because I'm scared
Oh, oh,
oh my God, that was scary.
I don't throw because I'm scared I'll betray myself if I
throw unless...
Oh, no!
One!
Ah!
Okay, okay, get...
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Go right in.
No!
Ah!
I'm free!
I was like, ha ha ha!
It's here.
Get my...
Is it here?
Oh.
Do we all hit her?
Are you fucking kidding me?
There's no way.
There we go.
She's stuck.
She got me again.
What can I do?
It's okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
What's wrong?
Okay, but I can't do it here.
Are you serious?
You'll bomb yourself.
You're gonna bomb yourself, you fucking idiot.
You're gonna fucking bomb yourself.
You're bomb yourself again, you fucking idiot.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Okay.
Now there's, I don't remember where they are.
I don't remember where the mines are.
I'm just gonna look at her movement.
We both, they both died!
Maybe not.
Maybe, maybe not.
Oh, yes!
Oh, I don't remember where the mines are.
I don't remember where the mines are.
Let's hope they're all.
Oh!
That was close.
Oh, that's close.
Oh my god.
The dragon and Ibu are on their second date.
Okay, we're at a tech.
A fucking red tech.
Wait, you can...
Oh my god, look, more aura.
Jesus.
The wist is...
The Ibu's landing out some more aura, guys.
It's illegal.
They can just fly.
How do you...
kill oh my god what i just i just stood next to him
oh i'm sorry let me just fucking i just got a heart attack
sorry guys they're aura farming
Sorry, I stubbed my toe on him.
I don't understand.
How are you so alive?
Like, can I just not kill them if they're farting?
Oh my god.
Just die to I boost.
I just...
Sorry, it's rude to chuck a bomb on them when they're
fucking tooting, I guess.
She's a ghost.
Then how do I kill him?
Okay.
My toky is a ghost.
Whoops.
I went too fast.
Oh, whoops.
There you go.
Is that how?
No, that's not how.
They just float across.
Okay, so when they're not doing their business, it was just
really rude to do it in the middle of ore farming.
I get it.
Don't they censor guards.
They only won by doing absolutely nothing.
I just keep stubbing my toe on their dead body under ghostly
bodies
how oh my on my face on my face oh i fucked up there it's
okay i timed it correctly
oh my god i killed myself okay okay okay okay Fuck though,
I'm too...
Oh, I just...
I just...
Boy, I got this.
I'm getting tilted right now.
I'm actually getting rage-filled and they're not even doing
anything.
They're just existing and I'm getting tilted.
all right okay i'm throwing at this point there's only two
of them the game just stopped sending more of them to the
game felt bad for me the game itself felt so bad for me i'm
just self sabotaging they're in my head they're in my head
now oh my god and she just flies over all the and she sends
out okay at least okay she hurts herself in confusion i i
take those i take those maybe she'll keep hurting herself
guys
just she'll just keep hurting herself that's the key don't
worry rapid eye movement you got this
okay i hurt myself in confusion apparently oh my god i keep
forgetting i keep bringing these iboos these iboos are just
made of bricks or some like if i touch them i get a heart
attack i keep forgetting that
I just got it.
I just need to make sure she doesn't spawn an eyeball on my
fucking head.
That's like my one fear right now.
One fear.
Where's the pickaxe?
Where is it?
many abu's guarding it oh i'm what i'm no clipping i'm no
clipping it's my turn to no clip
i didn't see my own farm
okay It's all right.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
Ah, we made her bomb!
No clips!
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine,
it's fine.
It's absolutely fine.
And she poops out an eyeball.
A fucking course!
Oh my god, fucking course her bombs no clips to a fucking
course What else can it do, huh?
Oh, she's just gonna poop on the eyeball.
I can feel it
Oh, oh, it was right there.
I keep forgetting that that no clip her bombs no clip
because they both look the same I don't know which was my
bomb and which was hers
here oh my god which one's hers and which one's mine I can
never tell Oh
god, I almost ran into my own.
Oh god, I almost ran into my own again.
Ah!
I'm going fucking...
Oh my god, I'm going fucking crazy.
Why is she so OP?
Oh my god!
And then she poops out and I poo on my face.
Because of course she does.
It's the controls.
It's the controls, guys.
I need to be able to...
Oh my god.
Z is so inconvenient.
Let me do mouse button.
Just let me do mouse button.
Or left click.
Oh my god.
I fucking ran into my own pop.
Okay, that one's my.
oh my god that was hers her stupid no clip bombs they're so
the goddamn ghost bombs
oh my god wait i can use two hands on my keyboard i don't
know why i have my why are my other hands on my mouse why
why are my other hands even on my mouse there's oh my god
why i'm i'm not even playing a mouse game what
and this game isn't even requires a mouse
the realization oh my god The fucking realization that...
I have two hands!
I...
Wait, where is...
I'm trapped!
Guys?
Did I not beat the game?
Did I do it?
Did I stop?
This is my purgatory.
How do I get out of it?
What have you been?
I
got saw blocked for using two ends.
I can't win.
I can't win in this world.
Now I just have to sit here.
I'll take myself out, I guess.
What?
I won and I can't even win.
I won, but she still won.
She just walks past my fucking bomb.
Even when I win, I still lose.
Oh my god, because I have two hands.
I can actually use my other hand.
Why would my other hand have my key for it?
Why?
oh my god
oh my fucking bitch
god damn be a demon
Bob okay okay okay okay okay I moved my hand a little too
fast and I thought I fucked up I thought I fucked up
That's it, that's it.
I thought I got detonated.
Did I not get detonated?
I guess that's just like...
Oh my god.
Oh, they did this.
I legitimately thought I fucked up there.
Oh.
Come on.
I just...
take myself out.
I don't even need her to kill me.
I'll do it first.
Oh my god.
I keep just...
I keep just self-sabotory!
Ah!
Don't you hate it when she just starts pooping a ghost on
you?
On you?
Oh my god.
When she just poops out her kids on your face.
Oh my god, where am I?
Where am I?
She doesn't even hurt herself anymore.
The AI just knows.
That's it, I'm just doing I'm doing this tech Surely this
tech will work
On myself Surely this tech will work On myself I'm doing a
classic bomber man's strat All bombs
It's all bombs!
Every bomb!
Oh my god, you bitch!
Okay.
It'll work.
It's just all bombs.
All bombs.
Every bomb possible.
She can't run away from all these bombs.
Oh my god, I keep...
But what about me?
I got lost.
There's too many bombs.
It was all bombs.
And then it was maybe too many bombs.
Oh my god.
The strat will work.
Oh, bombs.
Oh, there she poops a child.
It's like Groundhog Day.
This is the definition of insanity right now.
This is the definition of insanity.
just don't poop a chat don't poop an eyeball do not poop an
eyeball okay okay I got lost in the sauce where am I all
right okay we're gonna take it slow we gotta take it slow I
survived okay I almost killed myself there by I when I I
gotta take it slow.
No!
I'm in my own purgatory.
Every time I just...
I can't help it.
No!
I just want to take her down with me But I keep forgetting
she has another life I keep forgetting she has another life
And I was like, I got you now I'm my own worst enemy right
now
Get her Get her Wait, this is it Okay I gotta keep track of
the bombs.
Yes!
Oh no.
No.
No!
I don't know if I keep going crazy.
I'm going crazy.
I just keep bombing myself.
I'm my own worst enemy I just I just keep popping myself I
don't know what it is about this one level I rapid I just
want to be rapid I'm moving here
we go here we go There we go.
No!
I thought it was bad.
I keep forgetting how far the range is for my bombs.
They are pretty far, guys.
The no clipping is sort of confusing me, not gonna lie.
When I know clip it like fucks with my brain a little
Yeah All right
It just comes out of nowhere.
I just don't know when he comes over.
I just don't know when he shows up When does he show up?
I just can't stand behind There!
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I see that I still show up behind her.
Bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada,
bada.
No!
She's cheating.
She's literally cheating.
Look at her.
My steps!
Nerf her.
Nerf her to the ground.
Make her bombs tiny.
No, no clip.
She's stuck.
She can't float through the boxes.
Her eye boosts do nothing.
I demand new patch note.
I demand a hot fix.
Right now.
Give her...
If I touch her, she dies.
I have new balancing changes.
I...
Yeah, I have new balancing notes.
Okay, don't worry.
Maybe she'll bomb herself.
Bomb yourself now.
Oh, God.
I think I am soft-locked, though, because that... When I
killed her...
Okay, when she killed herself last time,
maybe...
She can't run away from all of this.
She ran away from all of it.
okay
okay there you go come on you have to move one day you have
to move one day
you're gonna have to move you're gonna
the move
oh my god i keep running i keep running too far
no oh uh it's fine it's fine it's fine It's fine, it's fine,
it's fine.
I might just keep getting eggs.
Oh, I need to remember.
I can't stand near her.
I can't.
She has so many defenses.
She can poop out eyeballs.
So I can't always stand near her, which sucks.
And then she can run through my own bombs.
Alright.
okay
all right guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you this has nothing to do with that
just Oh my gosh, she tried it.
Oh my gosh, she's just going to, every time I get close to
her, an eyeball just shows up.
Her little fucking bodyguards.
Oh my god, I keep forgetting my bombs go through that.
See, does he kill me if I go on him?
The fuck?
Oh, okay, it's a safe guy.
Okay, it's just a graphic glitch.
Okay, thank God
Like she has everything she might as well just walk through
this walk through the cinder block at this point Like why
just stop there?
You already gave her every single power-up imaginable like
You might as well just go all the way.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God.
God, damn it.
Oh, God.
I hate this.
What's the point of having obstacles if we can all just go
through the obstacles?
them just remove all the obstacles he's making me think i
can hide behind it
it makes me think i can hide it makes me think i'm blocked
by the boxes every time
oh my god i can get away from get away from me i will get
away from me
I swear to god she fucking spawns in an eyeball right now.
I swear to god
You're gonna it's gonna get you what it's gonna get you it's
gonna get you Yeah
Oh my gosh, she's gonna spawn.
I can't stand near her, too.
I can't stand here.
Fucking Ibu Defense Squad.
I get too...
I also get disoriented when there's too many...
When there's too many bombs!
Okay.
Just bomb yourself.
Bomb yourself now.
Oh,
he almost got me there.
You almost got me there with the eyeball.
Go.
No!
How many times do I...
I have
to kill you in the super chat.
Thank you.
How many times?
How many times do I have to kill you until I leave?
Until, until it's over.
But restart the game.
How many times do I have to kill you?
Okay.
Do I have to do it?
I have to do it all over again, don't I?
I have to do it.
I have to do it all over again.
Oh my god, I'm never free.
Oh my god.
Just a little...
A little tube to rub it in.
I thought...
You thought you were safe?
Toop!
Too close.
Fucking personal space, I guess.
Okay.
Okay, she bombed herself.
Good.
Oh my god, I almost ran through that.
Oh, there's too many eyeballs right now going.
Oh.
Oh my god, that was close.
Oh, oh.
Okay, that was close.
That was close.
I swear to God.
She got too close.
Come on.
Oh, I almost got too close.
I almost forgot the golden rule.
Come on.
Oh, don't you fucking dare.
Don't you...
Oh!
Are you kidding me?
Are you...
No!
Guys, I think I...
I'm just soft locked.
I think I'm just...
I...
Guys, guys, guys, I was just soft locked.
I didn't lose.
I was just soft locked.
I'm saying
So if I go through it, it'll be different to go around Oh,
okay, I have to go through the Uh Do not not go through the
blue portal Guys, see guys, it wasn't me It wasn't me, guys
Oh, I unlocked new characters, wait, can I Do I get their
power-ups?
Do I get their power-ups if I Become them?
Death's released The dokey patch.
Guys, guys, I was just soft-locked, guys.
He looks just like him.
Guys, I was soft-locked.
It's different.
I was just soft-locked, guys.
Guys.
Well, you have to get out of that egg someday.
That's fucking right.
There we go.
Let's see if there's any other...
I'm kept winning efforts for that song.
I have this honor DBS Maddie.
Thank you, man.
Let's see if we can...
Thank you.
Alright, let's see if there's any power-ups.
See it.
That's another poor...
Is there any like power-ups though?
There has to be one.
Okay, there's a bomb.
Nice.
I'm just a little faster.
See, it wasn't me.
I knew it.
I knew it wasn't me.
It was never my fault, guys.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
It wasn't me.
It's not me.
There we go.
That should kill him.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I need to actually get that.
I'm going the other way around.
Okay, so the one that's not the tomato.
Or not the sorry, not the...
That's not the green portal.
Is there another portal?
I knew it wasn't my fault.
I knew it.
It wasn't me.
Okay, nothing.
Alright, let's go through the...
Go through the portal.
I knew it.
It can never be me.
Yeah, how does the kick work?
What?
We're not up kick?
Oh, it's K.
Okay.
It's K.
Okay, wait, that works out for me.
That's fine, that's fine.
And I locked.
Oh, wait, the kick is so OP.
Wait, the kick is so OP.
Okay, I knew he was gonna fuck up his AI pattern soon.
Nice.
It's unlocked.
What?
Wait, am I fucked?
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I'm okay.
I'm calm now.
I'm...
Gus, thank you for the super chat thing.
That is not true.
It's because they gave up.
Mint fucking god mode.
She can no clip.
She can poop out eye blue so I can never get close to her
She can fucking go through my bombs and her bombs are max
range What the fuck am I like why have boxes?
Why the fuck even have boxes in the map?
It just confuses me because I keep thinking I keep thinking
that that is I have cover feel like I have cover, but I
don't because she can just go through everything.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Son, Tom, stuffed, Medi, Papa, Eagle, Nexi, Zerker, Netpers,
Meep, Vince, Fight, Anya, Quill, Jalakon, Alan, Rice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, I might as well, like, at this point, just make a go
through the cinder blocks.
to just make her fucking fly out of bounds and just punch me
like like i can't even touch her just add that in as well
chocolate jay thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you one hour
past i fear free you from the rumors thank Thank you and the
Akka super thank you, thank you.
That was a nerve-wracking, what?
How could it get worse?
How could it fucking get even worse?
She might as well, like, fucking come out and just pause.
Like, stop me from moving.
And it closes the game for me at this point.
Like, like, her move says, like, she randomly just closes
her game and you don't know when it'll happen.
Like, for real, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
Back from celebrating.
And maybe a wee bit tips, you can't get happy birthday.
Of course!
Of course, happy birthday!
Oh, you had a great birthday!
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Rappie!
Happy birthday to you Yeah, happy birthday Papa Smerp, thank
you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Min's kid is
overloaded Sir, sir, sounds like a mobile Excuse, thank you
for the super chat Thank you, thank you I only played
deadlock Cause I do it for him Do it for him, do it for him
Talking, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you
Can't believe Min is the Yeah, Jayla Khan, thank you, Super
Chat, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Doki, joining Ms. Dark Art B server.
All right, let's do this.
Remember, I have two hands on the keyboard.
I can use two hands.
I didn't remember that.
You can use two hands, Doki.
Don't even have the other mouse on the mouse.
oh my god
oh my god i'm fucking like oh boy i just got bitten
okay oh my god
i just i'm degrading i'm i'm actually my brain is declining
i'm gonna have alzheimer's any moment now i'm
she did this to me she did this to me she i like how the
game just locked everybody up after that i'm i'm lagging irl
right now the game was like maybe we gotta make this game
easier and have all the enemies locked up so they won't I'm
not sure anymore.
It's the only way.
It's her fault.
It's all her fault.
Keep forgetting it's K.
Everything was fine.
Everything was fine until that happened.
I don't know I don't remember the range so I'm like trying
to be careful
rapid I'm bowing girl thank you for the super chat talk to
Cranberry thank you thank you
I'm trying to find more upgrades right now whoops
I got one up.
I said that even matters, though.
Okay, this is safe zone.
Oh, nice.
Okay, that's punch.
Okay, punch.
And we have punch and kick now.
We got punch and kick.
Yeah, everything was fine until the finally.
Okay, there we go.
Are you serious?
wait i forgot she can fucking carry this right only arm arm
arm arm i don't remember what arm does what this arm do
what does arm do
oh my gosh she almost Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh.
Oh my god, we're kicking it everywhere.
What?
Ah, I freed her!
I freed her from her sins.
Okay.
Nice.
No, not nice.
Oh my god, this is bullshit.
This is so bullshit.
Oh, which one do I take?
Which one do I take?
There's a black portal.
There's a white portal and a blue portal.
I don't remember.
I don't know what to take.
Which one do I do it?
Guys, I have one minute left.
Okay.
Blue, the non-blue one.
Guys, guys.
Guys.
White or black?
The not blue.
Take blue.
Guys.
What is?
Do not.
Oh, not the blue one.
Okay.
White or black?
Just go black?
All right.
We'll do the black one.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, it's old time you want me.
Oh, I like this one.
This is nice.
I like this one.
I like the rag tunes.
That's what it's called, right?
I don't, I don't, I don't know.
I don't know.
Oh.
Alright, rag time.
I love rag time.
Oh my god, there's like a...
It's like if you double tap it, the bomb doesn't go out.
I love rag time.
Okay, nice.
I don't, but I don't, but I don't.
I don't trust myself because he's forgetting what the range
are from the are from the bomb so I'm like am I safe I must
be so safe and then I was not safe spoiler I died a lot of
bombs my bombs don't have any oomph power to them
that's my only issue right now Yeah, let's see if I have
anything in here.
All right.
Goodbye, black and white.
Oh, retro!
Because it's retro.
Oh, nice thing.
Ah!
Of course it goes through us.
A fucking curse.
Oh, my God.
Oh, and she just happens to have no clip, too.
has everything oh it's not about the size of the explosions
about how you use it guys oh my god what's the point oh my
god she's just saddened there because she knows she fucking
knows she knows that she can just no
oh my god he ran into my why why is there i boo What?
That's...
This is just mid-skit!
Enter's eye boost!
Just give me everything wrong with society!
Alright, there we go.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, I need that, actually.
Wait.
all right here we go we're gonna do it just might as well
make her invisible just just make her invisible at this
point okay i have a big explosion
but she takes she took my power up
okay she can just take my oh my god it's because she's a
thief it's because she's a thief oh my god
I can't
kill me.
I can't even go through anything.
I can't...
Oh, fuck!
And she has four HP.
How do I...
I could barely kill men.
And now you...
Oh my god.
That...
Kill...
I have to kill myself.
Yeah.
Oh my god, my god.
My bombs don't even go through.
Alright.
Oh my god, I swear to god.
I swear to god.
She starts pooping out eyeballs.
I swear to fucking god.
Oh my god, she bombed herself.
Bomb yourself now.
Alright.
What?
Yeah.
Oh my.
I
got to.
I got to.
I got to fancy with it.
I tried.
Ah!
I try to be fat I keep forgetting her bombs Go through
fucking walls
Okay Oh no No
No Okay it's fine it's fine it's fine Everything's fine
Okay Okay
Oh my god, I almost freaked myself out.
I'll take these.
Oh god!
Okay, she hurts herself.
She hurts herself in confusion.
Oh my god, oh god, oh god, that's close.
She's near to hurt herself.
Just hurt yourself.
Oh my god, oh my, oh my.
No!
Dang, I'm safe here.
nice come on come on oh my gosh she spawned too many
eyeballs they stopped moving they stopped taking oh no
oh i grieved i grieved myself i got so greedy i got so I was
trying to do something dumb And it was dumb I tried to do
something dumb And it was dumb Dumb
Oh my god, you really need it more.
Do you really need more bombs?
Do you really?
I don't care.
I don't care!
More bombs.
just just our bombs our bombs our bombs bombs everywhere wow
bombs for days I'm fine
whoops oh my god I couldn't come in so fast
oh my god I'm gonna die here That confused her, oh yeah.
There's so many bombs that confused her.
Oh my god.
I figured it out.
Surround her.
No!
I accidentally triggered the bomb.
There's so many bombs.
Too many bombs.
Ah!
It's too, too many bombs!
My biggest enemy is myself.
When there's too many bombs, I get disoriented.
Give me a... Give me a...
Okay,
she hurts herself.
She hurts herself out in confusion, just like me.
She's just like me.
real for real
okay okay
okay okay we're fine we're fine we're fine we're fine we're
fine we're fine we're fine we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine oh my god oh my god where am i where
Okay.
All right, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Oh god, there's too many bombs.
Too many bombs!
All right, all right.
One more, one more.
Please don't poop an eyeball.
too many bombs too many bombs too many bombs
did i do it oh my god
oh god oh god
maybe she'll get confused and then she'll run into my bombs
Just like how I'm confused right now.
Look at this beautiful bomb line.
Just run into one of them.
Stop!
Oh, that Aibu actually protected her.
Oh, she body blocked it.
Come on.
Confuse yourself.
Just confuse yourself.
Like, I'm confusing.
Wow!
She pooped in my life.
The one.
The fucker actually did it.
Get down, Mr. President.
You fucker.
Fuck.
This isn't even me!
This isn't even on me!
I already maxed out the bomb bomb!
I can't even get more bombs!
I can't even be faster anymore!
I've already maxed it all out!
Who
else can I use?
Oh my god, he just fucking uses she has everything she has
once she can use boxes for cover
There's so much on how many more I'm oh my god I just walked
into that I'm just I take my own way out I ended on my own
terms Boxer in with what she walks through boxes she walks
through bombs what box
What box?
How do I make a box?
I can't even box.
I can't lock her up.
I can't even...
She just uses my boxes as Calvary, but I can't even...
Do the same.
My only hope is that she hurts herself in confusion.
Oh my god.
I was actually so close.
I'm just gonna free up the fucking...
The fact that her bombs go through the boxes too fucks me up
too.
I thought it was, like, my own bomb, but it's not even my
own bomb.
I can't.
If I let the timer run now, I lose.
Oh, my God.
I love how she just walks through my bombs.
I love how she just walks through.
It's my favorite part.
Yep, that sounds about right.
And then I bomb myself.
I...
Oh, I trapped myself.
I was alright.
Bomb yourself now!
This is my only hope.
I just confuse her AI with my bombs and then she fucking
bombs herself.
Whoops.
she's like what the fuck is all of this and i was like i
don't know just bomb yourself
she just casually walks away she just like she doesn't even
have why why do you even have to run away.
Why do you even have to run away?
There's, you know, there's no, you're just role playing.
You're just role playing.
Oh my god, you even need to steal my power-ups.
You already have everything you ever wanted.
Her, ah!
A bomb into myself.
I deserve that.
Are you going crazy?
holy shit i almost killed myself
surprise motherfucker the the ibu drive by
Oh Like what do I even do?
I'm already locked
Oh, thank god.
Thank god she hurt herself in confusion or I would have done
done it to myself
Thank god that would have happened to me instead
and esteem thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
how the straggle experience treating you toky oh my god why
am i staying next to her she's just gonna start tuning out
in abu any moment now
okay we i got her and then she's gonna go here and now do
here and then I'll do here yes oh my god wait no I figured
it out I figured out I figured out your AI pathing bitch I
figured it out I just need to clear all of this
I figured it out I figured it out your AI I figured it all
out
Bob It sucks because like our bombs Look the same so I don't
know which one's My bomb and which one's hers
She sends her regards
Oh my god My bomb's so strong that I don't Remember that Oh
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
Just need to continue our pathing.
Oh my god, there's a fucking random eyeball.
Oh!
oh my god she's so she's so lucky she's so lucky there's so
many abu's just walking around
i'm i'm dead there was no thing i could do i did nothing i
could do i fucked up my own bad thing
okay Oh, I didn't see that.
I didn't even realize my bombs take up the whole screen now.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Wait, okay, I need to reset.
I need to reset.
There's too many iBOOS on my screen.
There's too many iBOOS, random iBOOS now.
It makes me get confused which one's the bad iBOOS and which
one's the good iBOOS.
Oh my god.
Okay, let me kill one of them.
them first okay
let me kill one of them first they take up the whole fucking
roll now let me get rid of them oh my god Okay, we got one.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice.
All right, we made her run.
Wait, that was risky.
That was so risky.
Okay.
No!
I got too cocky.
I keep getting greedy.
I see it.
The finish line.
I was just like, okay, gas, gas, gas.
Gas, gas.
Bet you, bitch, you, bitch.
You bitch, you bitch, you bitch, you bitch, you bitch, you
bitch, you bitch.
Yo, you poor fucking hort.
Sometimes you just gotta not love yourself.
Sometimes that...
Sometimes in life, some people just don't deserve to love
themselves.
Ah!
Ow!
I tripped on myself!
Oh my gosh.
I don't understand.
I'm just gonna let her take out all the boxes herself
okay why did I chose the black portal why did I chose the
fucking black portal guys why the did i do that to myself oh
my every time i feel like i got close every time
yes yes
oh my
god that's her bomb that's her bomb i was just like i'll be
saved that's my bomb right there no i got the timing wrong
don't put that bomb near me don't put that bomb near me
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I'm just making more room for myself.
Oh my god, why are there so many of them?
Can you get rid of these bombs?
Oh, oh, please don't make it to me.
Okay, now we can figure this out.
Now we can try and do this 1v1.
Stop caring.
I've given them.
I'm just I've accepted my feet whenever past Tokyo 1 she
gets I'm not even processing anything anymore oh my god I
swear to guide stop moving i swear the ibu hitbox is like 20
boxes or some there's no way
okay okay okay i'm just worried about the random ibu's
spawning in like just like that just like that just like
that oh my god i'm just i'm just so worried about the random
eyeballs coming in playing defense right now
bye okay i
just have to confuse the ai
Oh my god, she's going to spawn iBoo.
She's going to spawn iBooz any minute now.
I can't stand near her.
I have to wait until she starts spawning them in.
That's what I'm just worried about.
The moment I get too close to her.
Ah!
The moment I get too close and comfy.
Oh my god.
We were so close.
I'm just so scared.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh,
I have a box bomb at the bottom and a bomb at the bottom.
okay that hit her she got confused just like me she's just
like me for real for real
okay oh my god oh my god no
Oh my god.
Going fucking crazy.
Oh my god, stop!
Why can't you confuse yourself?
Confuse yourself now!
What?
Why did it go backwards?
Okay.
Oh my god, I almost confused myself now.
I almost confused myself.
I- Oh!
Because this eyeball has to die.
oh my god he just keeps running away oh my god oh my god i
almost fucked up
yeah yeah
okay all right wait wait wait wait wait
oh she confused herself she confused herself she fucking she
confused herself she confused herself right there we did it
no she did it she got confused
oh my god she actually confused herself now He did it.
Oh my god.
Confused yourself now.
I'm fine.
I don't care.
I'm free.
Free!
Oh, what are you gonna do?
You can't do anything!
That's right!
I went through hell!
I'm back here.
Round two.
She trapped herself.
She's just like me.
For real.
Oh no.
Hell returns.
No, not again.
Not again.
Oh my god.
And I even can kill it.
It's fine.
I need to grab the pickaxe.
It'll be my turn to go through boxes.
I just need to find the pickaxe.
pickaxe so I can reverse uno.
Okay, my turn.
Okay, guys, I need to get rid of this.
I need to get rid of this.
I need to...
There's too many eyeballs.
That cat.
I don't know which one's the fucking... Okay, there you go.
It's my turn.
Okay.
It's my turn Just have to remember I can't Can't stand too
close to her Or her little bodyguards come in Okay
Oh god that's close That's close
That's fine.
Here's fine.
My gosh, she knows how to go fucking up.
That's fine.
Oh, Suki, I slammed too hard.
My phone fell.
I slammed too hard.
At least the dragon and whisper having a nice day.
It's a little thing.
It's fine.
Oh,
she's so lucky.
She's so lucky.
I can't put bombs because there's boxes there.
I need to get rid of these guys.
Oh my god, I didn't see the bottom bomb!
I'm going crazy, I'm going crazy.
I'm fucking sending it all in.
I'm fucking sending everything in.
I don't have nothing to lose.
I'm nothing to I I'm nothing to lose I'm alive okay
Oh my god, Ticaki.
Nothing to lose, Tried!
Okay.
Oh my god, she's tilted.
She's...
Toki, are you sure?
Are you sure she's the tilted one?
I...
I'm sure...
I'm sure she's the tilted one.
oh my god bomb yourself now bomb yourself now bomb yourself
now
okay oh my i couldn't move there for a second
Oh She's so lucky.
She's so lucky.
She's so oh My god, I almost fucked up there I need to clear
up the screen I just anyway, there's like 20 eyeballs in
front of me that aren't like like it just it just
disoriented me because i'm like that's not the real one
right it was the real one it was the real one this is the
trap of like nothing to lose trap the nothing to lose trap
just send it all in if i live i live self-destruct mode i
did it and i'm still here I'm still here.
I'm still here.
I beat the game.
This is a win.
I win.
I beat the game.
I'm trapped.
I call that a win.
I won.
I won!
It's over!
I had the high ground!
My strat of nothing to lose strat!
Just throw every bomb I have and hope I survive!
Yoki wins!
Yoki fucking wins!
The strat works!
This is the strat.
Random bullshit go.
We did it.
I didn't think I would...
I didn't think I'd be stuck in this game.
With just one level.
I think I might call it here, guys.
I think I might need to call it here.
I'll look at the other perfect stuff on the next stream, but
I've never slammed my table this hard in a long time.
I might have accidentally had free nourishment.
Thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
I need it.
My voice is gone now and I need it.
My voice is gone.
I don't think I can go longer.
I won.
And by the end of the day, I won.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Go to him, Doki.
Go to Rem.
He'll be there for you.
He'll be...
Huge shout out to all the dragoons that worked so hard on
this game.
I really appreciate it.
It was a blast.
But do have some notes on your next game.
update for your next balance patch you should make it so
that mint goes through a box she dies if I touch her she
dies if she's when she spawns in an Ibu and Ibu touches her
she dies every time she puts out a bomb she dies and also
she should be like 0.5 centimeters tall and her bombs are so
tiny like don't even see the explosion she puts out a bomb
the bomb explodes and then like nothing happens
whereas I demand the dokey patch I demand the dokey patch
and you guys thank you so much for coming thank you she
breathed she fucking dies in fact she can't even move she's
just there she just stands there She can't even move.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I hope you guys had fun hanging out with me.
And again, cute shout out to Dragons for working so hard on
this game.
It was really fun.
I cannot wait for the future updates you have for it.
And as always, everybody, say hi, Jada, Pasha check.
Get up and move around.
Get that back.
blood flowing and if you except for me head to bed because
you deserve it I'm gonna go rest now my voice is gone now so
I need to rest my vocal cords and thank you for hanging out
thank you guys thank you again for everybody for just you
know just hanging out supporting the stream it really means
a lot and for the lovely birthday gift thank you dragon I
know so much love and hard work was put onto this game
itself so I really appreciate that you guys did so much for
on my birthday and I'm so glad I was finally able to check
it out.
All right guys, I gotta go now.
Bye bye everybody.
Bye.